[Music]
psalmist writes unless the Lord builds
the house those who built it labor in
vain we have cause to think that this is
the largest classical chapel built in 70
years the question is not why we built
this when you walk in here don't you
look up and think of the ultimate things
the answer to that question is obvious
the hard question is why have others not
I think it is a turning away from things
that are beautiful
which means necessarily then also things
that are true and things that are good
when the truth and the beauty and good
are gone then of course all reasons the
demand we strive to become good human
beings are gone it is actually the
purpose of the activity of the college
to explain and understand all that and
that activity goes on intensely now for
175 years
this is a very special occasion 170
fifth anniversary of Hillsdale and the
dedication of this beautiful Chapel the
chapels enduring Beauty highlights the
transcendence sovereignty and the grace
of God it truly illustrates how
architectural design can reflect the
character of God and evoke a sense of
reverence for his majesty
[Music]
you're gonna hear a lot in the coming
months about the for purposes of this
college learning character faith and
freedom these are the principles of
education here at Hillsdale have been
for 175 years and we hope it will be
another 175 years we live in an age of
confusion that has become dangerous
threatening tyranny
the only thing ultimately that can spell
it is understanding this college was 175
years ago to give that understanding
where ever anybody wanted to learn you
and God have given us the means to make
that big thank you
[Applause]